ryan lochte and fiance Kayla read turned
heads at George Clooney's annual
Halloween party hosted by casamigos
tequila Friday night the newly engaged
couple who stepped out as the mad hatter
and Alice in Wonderland spilled on their
wedding plans to ET well right now I'm
on Dancing with the Stars so once that's
over then we're gonna start planning but
i think we decided like august/september
ya next fall and any idea of where you
want to have the wedding um I'm thinking
we're gonna have it in the round on the
west coast yes I can't wait earlier this
month ryan told ET his entire Dancing
with the Stars family is invited to his
big day have a huge huge party and he
and dance partner Cheryl Burke are
planning a special routine for the
reception will you teach him a special
dance for his wedding wedding yeah I
told him I said you should just do that
contemporary routine flip tail up in the
air bend over you don't like to be
really beautiful I like doing different
things so you know what i am gonna mix
the waltz contemporary what else do we
love hip-hop little cha-cha salsa i'm
gonna mix it all in one day in every way
I would love to see you friend have
Kayla get ready
you